[Music]
the rule of law you may have heard about
it in your history class but do you
remember what it means
it basically ensures that a democracy
doesn't turn into a dictatorship
it states that all men are equally
subject to the law
even the lawmakers themselves but what
we take for granted in our european
democracies
is currently at stake it's mostly the
case in poland and hungary
in the second episode of what's left we
explore the challenges facing the rule
of law
and why we must fight to defend it
[Music]
george beata moravid is being prosecuted
by the current polish government
namely the ruling law and justice party
more commonly known as
peace an ultra conservative and populist
party that's in power since 2015
[Music]
[Music]
is now facing up to 10 years of prison
on the fabricated charges of corruption
she is not alone in poland she is just
one of the many polish judges
that the peace government is trying to
silence to take control over the
judiciary and destroy the separation of
powers in poland
they are doing this in open defiance of
the polish constitution
and even ignoring the rulings from the
european court of justice
is poland leaning towards an
authoritarian regime we ask the question
to mr chimoshevich former prime minister
and justice minister of poland
i have no doubt that this is the
intention of the of the people
ruling the country to center the
autocratic power
and it is more and more visible
especially recently when they use force
against
peaceful protesters when they persecute
independent judges
when they persecute the opposition this
is
this is nature of autocracy but the
problems go well beyond
the independence of the justice system
and affect fundamental rights
such as media freedom the protection of
women's rights and minorities
look at what happened last october in
poland with abortion rights
the constitutional court now in the
hands of the peace government
made it illegal for women to abort even
in cases when the fetus has severe
defects
making the polish law on abortion one of
the most restrictive in the world
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of polish citizens
took to the streets to defend
abortion rights in one of poland's
biggest protest movements in recent
years
unfortunately polish people are not the
only ones
facing worrying attacks on the democracy
the situation is actually even worse in
hungary where the prime minister viktor
orban
in power for the last 10 years decided
to build an illiberal state
he looked for russia and china as good
examples
[Music]
orban's fetish party has imposed
restrictions and increased its control
over the opposition
the media religious groups the academic
world
ngos the courts asylum seekers
and the private sector it has acted with
a sense of complete impunity
under the protection of the european
people's party which fidesh is still a
member of
so how did we get to this point we asked
the question to clara de rev
vice president of the european
parliament an outspoken opponent to the
urban regime
unfortunately my answer is that it was
all possible because of
european funding because european union
gave
a lot of funds for development and a big
part of these funds went to the hands of
oligarchs
and european union was weak in a sense
that
they could not control that those money
would should go to the civil
organization to local government to
people
and instead of that the money went to
the big oligarchs so they started to buy
media they started to create civil
organization they started to buy
all kind of industry and to build up a
big power
which is very difficult now to defeat
in poland and hungary the lgbti plus
community is also being targeted
by populist politicians and nationalist
groups
dozens of local authorities adopted
anti-lgbt
resolutions declaring their territories
free from lgbti ideology
even the president of the polish
republic anja duda
openly questioned the human dignity of
lgbti
[Music]
in hungary we may not have lgbti free
zones yet
but the cultural war against them is
raging as well
since the government is trying to
effectively put a ban on gay adoption
i'm from germany and when you hear gay
people
describing standing in front of a
restaurant and it says on the restaurant
homosexuals are not welcome for me as a
german
i hear something else i hear what we
what we experience what germans did
in the 1930s 1940s this is so dangerous
we should never
allow something like this to rise again
i remember 10 years ago when we saw the
first
very serious signals from hungary people
looked away
they thought this is a temporary thing
and then we saw it spill into one of the
biggest member states into the european
union
in poland thinking if hungary can get
away with it
we can too and look at where we are
today in 2020
when we have a government for instance
in bulgaria
or a government in slovenia following
the same
autocratic path and these people are
also being examples
for populists in western europe the
ruling parties in hungary and poland
argue that because they won the election
democratically
they have the right to reform their
countries and defend as they claim
their identity and traditional values
mr lopez aguilar is a former justice
minister of spain
and is now a snd member in the european
parliament
[Music]
we have seen that in two countries of
recent accession
poland and hungary democracy has been
forsaken
because democracy is not only winning
elections and running by your majority
is also respecting minorities who have
every right
to oppose you because minorities of
today in democracy
may turn to be the majority of tomorrow
[Music]
why does any of this matter to the
european union
the eu is based on the mutual trust
between countries that they will respect
the rule of law
the independence of the judiciary and
the primacy of eu law
if all of a sudden one government
decides not to play by the rules
then the whole project is damaged
the treaty on the european union states
clearly from the very beginning
all member states must respect the rule
of law and the eu's fundamental values
if you don't agree on common values and
on common rules
you can't have a common market you can't
have
mutual trust you can't have exchange of
data for example
companies can't have trade and have
confidence that
if there is a problem they are in front
of independent judges
so it comes down to this
to join the eu poland and hungary had to
comply with a set of criteria
the so-called copenhagen criteria
according to which they vowed to respect
the rule of law
human rights and minorities
[Music]
now the question is what happens if a
country already inside the eu
suddenly does a u-turn on these values
first of all the commission can start an
infringement procedure that can end up
in the european court of justice the
eu's highest legal authority
which can eventually impose a financial
penalty on a member state
it worked when poland tried to pass a
bill on the early retirement of supreme
court judges
it was designed to get rid of
independent judges including mao gajata
geritorf
the president of the polish supreme
court under the pressure of big
financial fights
the peace government gave up this was a
historic victory for the vice president
of the european commission
franz timmermans the problem is that
these infringement procedures take a lot
of time and the rulings may simply come
too late when the damage is already done
in theory the eu also has the
possibility to suspend a member state's
voting rights in the council
this is known as the article 7 procedure
and was launched for the first time
against poland and hungary in 2017 and
2018.
to punish a particular country you need
the unanimity of all other member states
in the european council
poland and hungary already announced
that they would veto any sanction
against one another
we have the so-called article 7
procedure
which is not working by now first of all
it takes a lot of time
and second even that we criticize
member state and are alerted because the
rule of law is not respected
nothing is happening because the council
is not taking any decision
and according to our rules the council
is the only institution who could work
on it
[Music]
the socialists and democrats have been
calling for years for a new much
stronger broader and faster eu mechanism
to protect democracy
the rule of law and fundamental rights
with potential financial consequences
european citizens agree a recent opinion
poll
shows that 77 of europeans insist that
eu funds should be linked to the respect
for the rule of law
the snd group fought hard in the
negotiations on the new long-term eu
budget
and the coronavirus recovery fund
again poland and hungary were
threatening to veto but the final result
is that for the first time the eu will
have a mechanism linking the budget to
the rule of law
however it may take some time before it
becomes operational
as hungary and poland will almost
certainly challenge it in the european
court of justice
with this new mechanism if a member
states is abusing
the justice system they can be
sanctioned so they are not going to have
in the end access to eu funds in the
future we are going to discuss
the future of the european union and i
think it would be a good opportunity to
enlarge
the scope and the effectiveness of the
of these new mechanisms but this is a
first step and this is a good step
and social democrats the word in itself
says it already
we don't just care about welfare and
prosperity for all
but also about freedom about the respect
for democracy about the respect
for minority rights social democrats
care about prosperity
but also freedom for all